As an Indie game developer you’ve been there.
Those sleepless nights. Those programming glitches.
It seems like your first big hit game is sooo far away.
You have heard about the legend of Indie Games Accelerator:
...a program by Google Play through which Indie Developers bring their ideas to life..
...and build epic games and great adventures that people will love.
Selected participants are flown to Google Asia's headquarter in Singapore...
...where they receive direct coaching from the best mobile gaming experts in the world, ...
...and some game-changing rewards like Google Pixel phones, Google Cloud credits, and exclusive events invites!
Missed your chance last time?
Well, start your engines, cause a brand new adventure is about to begin!
Applications to the 2019 class of Indie Games Accelerator are now open...
...and this is your opportunity to supercharge your business on Google Play.
We are now welcoming passionate game developers from select countries...
...in Latin America, Africa, Middle East and Asia - who are looking to supercharge their game….
...and reach new heights.
Apply for the program today, and give your game the next level-up!